plugging in a second controller to make
your character run faster sounds like
the setup for a bad video game meme
however that's exactly how some players
have discovered you can do so in Pokemon
scarlet and violet even though the setup
is a bit more complex than viral social
media posts will have you believe as one
popular tweet shows yes it is true that
you can double your character's run
speed in scarlet and violet by pressing
forward onto controllers at once however
your switch must be undocked and you
have to use a joy-con attached to the
switch along with a wireless controller
the game apparently confuses the
attached joy-con and the wireless
controller which allows both controllers
to provide input to the character
simultaneously as one reply to the
original post shows this doubled input
allows the joystick to go beyond its
normal range thus significantly
increasing the speed of your character
we were able to get this trick to work
in our own testing though it doesn't
work if you go directly backwards or
directly forwards which makes navigation
a little bit more annoying than usual
this Speed Run worthy exploit is just
one of many issues that Pokemon fans
have reported with scarlet and violet
another exploration glitch making its
way around the internet is one that
allows you to get up slopes that are
impeding your progress a clip posted to
Twitter by Zully the witch shows her
attempting to jump up a slope and
sliding down then she turns around and
leaps up the hill backwards successfully
making it up and if you're interested in
trying it yourself the key is to mash
the jump button as you descend once you
get a little bit further into the game
and get abilities like Glide and climb
the trick might be a little harder to
pull off however with those additional
movement tools you probably won't need
it as much while this latest entry in
the series has garnered positive review
scores this open world Pokemon
experience is marred by significant
technical flaws including low frame
rates visual glitches and frequent
stuttering however our critic jig Decker
still enjoyed the experience in our
Gamespot review of the games I am also
having a pretty great time even though
the stuttering makes my eyes hurt in
other Nintendo related news the Mario
Kart 8 Deluxe Booster course pass will
soon be halfway to the Finish Line as
the third wave of six has been confirmed
for a December 7th launch date Wave 3 of
the booster course pass will like the
previous waves add 8 more courses to
Mario Kart 8's roster with all of them
coming from previous games in the
franchise there's we Maple Tree Way from
Mario Kart Wii DS Peach Gardens for
Mario Kart DS and 3DS rainbow road from
Mario Kart 7 just to name a few Wave 3
comes over four months after the release
of the previous wave which brought the
turnip cup and propeller Cub on August
4th the booster course pass is available
as a separate purchase for 25 and it's
also included in the Nintendo switch
online plus expansion pass subscription
along with access to classic games from
the Sega Genesis and N64 days hit the
comment section let me know who you
picked as your starter in scarlet and
violet and we'll see you in the next one